heather gay can we dive right in you've
just survived
your first reunion how did it go
it went great from what i can remember
i mean it's all a huge fog
like bits and pieces are coming in did
that happen and i don't know if it was
what i anticipated happening if it's
what a dream or nightmare i've had post
or if it occurred so i i'm kind of in a
fog of everything but
overall the top notes of it was amazing
and a rainbow of emotions and a
beautiful set
and andy cohen was chef's kiss was that
your first time
meeting andy in person and he was
everything you wanted him to be and more
i know you've had like a long
time crush on andy cohen 2014
i posted a picture of him with just the
caption i love andy cohen so
this is yes six years going this is not
a fly-by-night affection if you will
so yeah all of that was i was totally
starstruck and starstruck by
the experience of it all okay you called
it both a dream and a nightmare so there
was good
there was bad what what can you tease me
with what's gonna surprise the viewers
about what goes down
from what you can recall yeah i think
just the level of emotion
you know like we got into it we just
really did it was much more intense
than i anticipated it being i didn't
realize how much
kerosene was in the room well you know
the the instagram detectives were doing
all their work that day and seeing who's
unfollowing who who's posting what
cryptic thing
was there more healing done or new drama
started
or is it a combination i mean if i could
remember
i would answer i don't really know how
to answer that because there was some
resolution and there was some
you know ripping open of new wounds for
you personally just your experience oh i
won right
i won the whole thing i won the reunion
i want the whole reunion i'm just
kidding no that's not true
but did you walk away feeling like there
was closure to things that you needed
closure on or do you feel like there are
wounds
still left open for you i am a gaping
open wound
there's that there is no there's no
sutures in the world for
the wound that i am so yeah i'm still
definitely
you know limping through life you know i
yeah that's a hard one you're gonna have
to watch
i will be watching i'm anxiously
anticipating what does a mary cosby at a
reunion look like and i think there are
a lot of questions about mary people
want answered so hopefully we get some
of those answered there
you'll see a lot mary spoke up you'll
see a lot from mary and
you know none of us were singing kumbaya
but i think everyone was heard
everyone was heard some people were
maybe hurt
okay we have a few weeks left of the
show to watch though until we get
those reunion episodes when you look at
this whole
journey so far i mean it's kind of been
wild overall what's this experience been
like for you is it everything you wanted
it to be
it's been transformative i've been
reinvigorated with like humanity and
the community that's out there and the
love and connections you can make
through social media and through
television and so i
feel like i have a new lease on life and
i feel hopeful and i'm emotional about
it because
i had resigned to just kind of you know
pedaling the back seat of the
tandem bike for my kids and for my
family you know and so i never
really thought that this opportunity and
this type of
chance would cross my path so i feel
grateful
and i feel lucky it had to have been
cool when rihanna slid into the dms and
gave you the stamp of approval
it made me feel like [ __ ] get your act
together you know what i mean like don't
let rihanna down
like don't cry i'm divorced i'm mormon
you know like pull your panties up
rihanna's watching you know she's not
gonna play
so yeah that was huge i didn't believe
it but once i
made sure and verified it was her like
yeah it makes me level up i want to
level up a little bit
what did you message back to really anna
and how long did it take for you to
message back
like first of all i like googled
instagram bots
and how they work because i didn't want
to expose myself
unnecessarily so i thought maybe you
fished a little bit
and then she had said you know i'm
obsessed with you and i just said uh
same like this is
like given like i am obsessed with you
and she damned me back kind of like a
just a feminist punch in the arm like
listen keep it real keep it you know
and keep doing you and you're on the
right trajectory
and then i dm back like i won't let you
down real quick
yeah you didn't send a thumbs up
whatever i have to do
in watching yourself back have you
learned anything about yourself
yeah i'm hideous right that is not true
that is take that no no no you are
letting rihanna down by saying that
sorry
sorry no i've learned that i am um
i'm not very cool you know like i'm just
like clapping like a seal and everything
and cheering
and everybody and you know and i love
food if i can make eye contact with her
i'll go over
okay i can't i'm gonna wait for my
lollipop chicken drumsticks
i said when we started this is kind of
like an aggressive mirror it shows you
a lot and the things that i thought it
was gonna show me was not my love of
meatballs
you know it was not my inability to
speak my mind you know so it's
it's been fascinating to watch and
cringy for sure
it's cringy but all those moments are
the reason why everyone has fallen in
love with you you get that right
that's the only icing on the cake man
otherwise i'd be like i'm out
i can't do it has watching the show back
changed your perception of any of your
co-stars
no but i would i would be remiss if i
didn't say that i have
i gained deep respect for meredith
because i feel like she really has
opened up her marriage and her life and
i don't so i really was impressed by
that
and moved by it by seeing the intimacies
of her and seth's relationship and i
love that couple
i love that way that they speak about
marriage i think it's healthy and
progressive
and um i'm into it so that was that was
surprising to me
something that's been surprising to me
is how quickly we've moved on from the i
don't know her
um okay we have not moved on we have not
moved on
rice we're gonna circle back you know
what i mean okay
is it in the episodes or at the reunion
both
um reunion mostly did you bring any
receipts
of you knowing her because elisa told me
she had receipts of when she claims to
have met you
right yeah we've all had receipts but i
already told you i won right
so if you want okay
i'm picking up what you're laying down
here that to me is
a housewife uh debate that will go
stand the end of time because it is
truly
we're both right i mean i can't recall a
housewife show that started in the first
episode with
two feuds that are like
on par with top level housewives feuds
i don't know her in hospital smell you
guys came out the gate
ready to play i mean i would watch if i
wasn't on it i would watch
but you kept playing we left off at the
implosion
of jen at the uh at coach shaw's
birthday party
you're not afraid of her no not at all
why would i be afraid
i'm not afraid of any of you just that
he is
has jen always been this reactive or are
her reactions more than you anticipated
um filming the show i thought she would
hold back for cameras
i thought the pressure of appearing i
don't even know
just normal it would hold would keep us
all
kind of under ups but no i i have seen
jen react like that
many many many times off camera when
she's upset she that's
how she responds do you regret being a
part of whitney's
uh delivery of the message at that
moment or do you think you being there
actually helped the situation because
whitney was not at full faculty in that
moment
you were good with meredith and lisa
right like you had a clean site
so i was really surprised to hear this
week that
maybe there wasn't a clean slate because
let me let me start over on this
conversation listen whitney is
my girl there's no question about that
and i felt like a weird
stage mom like you know your words
remember
they called mary i was just like i would
have been like i would have
said this isn't let's abort or possibly
like what we really were trying to say
which we couldn't say
is the way you're reacting isn't just a
problem for the
the inbreds it's a problem for everybody
even the ones that you're trying to
impress
so this is a universal issue that we
want you to know about and address so
yes i would we would redo the whole
thing but i would never
not show up for whitney regardless of
the outcome
ever who do you believe do you believe
that they're afraid of jen or do you
think mary made that up or is the truth
somewhere in between
i think the truth is always somewhere in
between but i think you would have to be
some sort of
masochist to not live afraid of jen's
reactions that's a
it's not a character flaw to be
terrified i think we're closer to the
truth than we are
a lie okay was this resolved at the
reunion will we get an answer one way or
the other on that
from no because they're both right
you know and that's what makes the great
feuds of time
well we know this trickles into the next
episode and likely beyond
the next episode um there's this soaking
tub
in nature moment that leads to a fourth
wall breaking moment with jen
like i trusted you guys as my friends
and whitney
roll your mother guys and look over
there one more time i'll drown you [ __ ]
i'm not rolling my eyes jen
[Music]
that's what happens when you feel me in
the bathtub
were you surprised she took it to that
place yeah i was surprised that anyone
including whitney jumped out of that tub
since
it was middle of winter zero spray tan
zero bubbles like i was
i price i was not getting out of that
tub for anything i didn't care if
the hillside caught on fire and still
there i had a robe and like
a circle you know shower curtain to get
dressed in
so yeah that was it's always shocking to
me because i am
i try to be a rule follower i'm a people
pleaser so
i love watching people that don't
please live vicariously through them
um but you do have a real moment with
jen in that moment too where you
tell her i am afraid of losing your
friendship
yeah that was a real moment it was
poking an old wound with me with jen
trying to kind of level up to lisa and
meredith so
will dramatic and cringy and
embarrassing for me
as a human it is it was true
you know i um my whole life i felt my
friends trade up when the opportunity
presented and that's hurtful and that
never heals i guess
i think a lot of people can relate to uh
that feeling
uh what i'm picking up here is this
through line of jen
you've seen jenna's trying to impress
the cool girls
all season long which is not it's not
something i had really picked up on
until you say this
it's there for sure we did see kind of
on that note of
feeling like you're going to be left
behind or someone trades up
your ex-husband appeared on the show
which i was not
expecting to see him at all um talk to
me about
what kind of convincing did it take to
get him on board
you know there's the angel in the devil
over shoulder i was glad for it because
you know
he's the reason any of my life has
existed this reason i have these
daughters and
he's the reason i'm so traumatized so
there's there's
all good but i was shocked kind of too
that he's just been unaffected
by a lot of it and it's just an
interesting dynamic so
while he's not supportive of like my
life choices
he'll always kind of show up for the
girls in that capacity
so i was grateful in the long run
because that's our life
so that's for good or bad that's that's
what my life is
he's in my life every day so i remember
on watch kevin's live you shared his
initial reaction i think to the trailer
coming out
which was real classy thumbs down has
his perception changed at all
having seen your experience with it and
the girls experience with it
seeing me kind of come out to the girls
and talk about the divorce and
seeing that raw side of my emotions he
reached out and texted me and was really
kind
and just said it was hard for me to you
know and
i never wanted to
destroy you know our plans and i think
that was
hugely positive because we're we don't
speak of things we don't discuss things
and i think that was hugely positive
because
we don't speak of things we don't
discuss things i mean of course i just
left him on red
it's too much all too much well we've
we saw you dip your toe back into dating
we'll use the term dating i don't know
that we really saw you go on a date
you will eventually this season you will
what are you looking
for in a partner for this next stage of
your life oh my gosh
i just want someone that's fun and
loves sex and loves food and loves
just not taking ourselves too seriously
you know
just like i want someone that'll be a
teenager with me i never really got to
be
you know 21 and carefree and i i kind of
want to pretend i am
and not be shamed for it you want your
good time guy to go with your good time
girl phase got it
where is he that's exactly what i want
do you feel like you can find that
yeah especially after watching 90 day
fiance i feel like
if i can really throw some money around
i can find someone that just wants to
you know
get a fancy watch show up we don't even
have to communicate much we can speak
in tinted sentences but i'm into that
bryce that's kind of the level that i'm
looking for
okay i'm gonna say don't do that that's
my baseline that's the type of
commitment i'm
interested in let's just uh my 95th day
fiance is real darkhead i don't want you
guys
in these last few episodes we are headed
on a trip las vegas
yes what happens in vegas does not stay
in vegas it gets broadcast on tv for
millions of people to see
what are we gonna see in vegas more
drama than fun
more drama than good times good time
girl didn't get to really
spread her wings in vegas unfortunately
when i think back to the trailer
i believe there's a moment where lisa
corners you and whitney
and it says i hold myself to a high
standard if you don't want the saint
sanders
go away what can you tell me about that
moment well lisa was you know
teaching us much as she teaches her
family
how to be better
and whitney and i were listening but it
was um yeah lisa was
lisa became the peace broker in that
moment
of everything going on and you know
we're in trouble when lisa barlow is the
voice of reason i'll tell you right now
i'll just go on record saying that so
it definitely took a turn in vegas at
some point i was gonna say
that does not feel like a peacemaking
moment so the fact that that is the
peacemaking moment
is quite something so that's her
building a bridge bryce she was building
a bridge
who is involved in the drama that she
was trying to fix
all of us every single one of us is mary
on this trip to vegas i was looking at
the footage and i could not find her
mary did not come to vegas she opted not
to come
wisely but we do call her
you know while we're there and lisa's in
touch with her too
is that who in the trailer you are
facetiming with someone in a hotel room
and you're
like she is like lying to us all oh no i
was i was talking to
my friend angela who's mutual friends
with me and lisa
and knows everyone on the cast okay
you're getting a
someone outside of the circle that can
speak to the circle party
maybe not that objective if they know
everybody so someone that would agree
with everything i was saying
basically and you know everybody is
anxiously anticipating news of a season
two which i know will have to
wait a minute till we hear anything
seems safe to say we'll get one but
should we get a season two what would
you like to explore in a second season
of the real housewives of salt lake city
90 day fiance man i would like to have a
love i would like them to cast a love
interest
for 12. not how this works i would like
to feel like someone is in love with me
for 12 weeks i want to make out and go
on dates on camera
and then have them ship off to a soap
opera in venezuela or something later
you know i don't care
but i would love to i feel like for the
first time i'm kind of living
authentically
so that might allow myself to attract
you know a partner
do you feel like the show helped you
live authentically
forced me to help helped is like a fire
hose for a drink of water bryce
forced me to live authentically as it
should have
and how sad for me that that's what it
took but i have to
be honest that's what it took but also
how great that it happened
true true and has the reaction from the
mormon church been
better worse or not at all what you
expected it to be
it's been exactly what i expected to be
and it's been bad
and how does that impact
kind of your i guess more your
daughter's
relationship with the religion yeah in a
way it makes it
easier to walk away you know what i mean
it's like when you break up with
somebody then they're a dick you're like
okay
i was on to something you know so
there's there's an element of that that
i'm
grateful for because it allows me to
[Music]
distance